monsieur coquerel bonjour et merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors
vous le dites en vous en vous ne vouliez
pas laisser le monopole de l'information
au gouvernement c'est de ce constat que
vous êtes parti pour cette commission
enquête
oui absolument une autre constat c'est
que quand vous savez il n'y a pas de
commission d'enquêté à l'assemblée
j'espère qu'on va pas revenir en avoir
une dans les semaines à venir mais c'est
pas la mission d'information nous a été
concédée et rookie qui tourne très
souvent en espèces de conférence de
presse du gouvernement
on va rentrer se roule donc on a décidé
de vous en commission dans lequel on a
auditionné près d'une centaine de
personnes
nous n'avons pas reliés par des
professeurs de maleville ont fait partie
des soignants des syndicalistes eux
mêmes des chefs d'entreprise
enfin des gens qui ont été confrontées à
la crise pour essayer de dire ce qui
s'est passé le bilan qu'on en tire
confirme nos impressions c'est à dire
qu'il ya eu à la fois des erreurs
terribles du commises et puis
globalement un système qui est soulignée
au libéralisme qui jaillirait est en
crise parce que c'est lui qui a
transformé une crise épidémique en tri
sanitaires et crise sociale la force de
baisser les dépenses publiques apporte
deux blessés d'attaquer la santé
publique
à force de délocaliser de les priver de
toute souveraineté sanitaires etc etc
c'est l'exploit à dire c'est le constat
que nous faisons le bilan est plutôt bon
dans ce document alors une enquête vous
venez de le dire qui parle d'erreurs
mais aussi de mensonges sur quoi selon
vous le gouvernement français a menti à
ses citoyens
il a beaucoup menti au nom un exemple
les masques j'ai vu qu'hier le chef de
l'état continue à estimer qu'il est
peut-être péril pénurie de masques
j'ai dit en plaisantant qui va nous y
reviendrons que la terre est plate parce
que loin que plusieurs c'est tout le
monde a constaté le pdo ring masques et
nous savons tous que
la question cette question qui la
question qui s'est posée par cette
pression qui s'est posé ces a été due à
une politique qui a pimenté ripasso
votre gouvernement
c'est donc qui fait qu'on est arrivé
dans ce pays signe un puissance
économique au monde sans un seul masque
ffp2 à dire une seule masse qui
permettent à des soignants jeanine r&d
totalement immunisé par rapport aux
virus et pourtant on a levé allemand qui
a pas arrêté de dire à l'heure à jour en
réalité vous n'avez pas besoin de base
tout ça parce que je n'avais pas un
autre jour si si nous devenons des
baskets ou l'espagne on savait que
c'était pas vrai que je recevais pas de
l'état débrouiller eux mêmes
il est des masques avec des imprimantes
3d donc il ya déjà mon change du masque
mais à mon sens du test aujourd'hui même
on loupe le gouvernement nous assure que
pour le déconfinement express est servie
test par semaine ça fait cent mille
tests pardo on sait qu'on n'en est pas
là boîtier encore c'est un mensonge
mensonge et municipales aussi parce que
très clairement ces élections ont été
organisées alors même que le
gouvernement depuis fin janvier par un
amusant c'est elle qui le dit avait été
avertie de la dangerosité du virus
et j'allais dire de du caractère
compliqué de faire les municipales
autant le principe de précaution n'a pas
été appliquée on pourrait comme
s'accumuler les les éléments qui vont
effectivement malheureusement il ya des
erreurs il ya un système en faillite
mais il ya aussi des mentions alors on
voit n'y a pas que le gouvernement
français qui est en difficulté en c'est
le monde entier qui a été un peu gens me
dire pris de court par cette épidémie
est ce que selon vous l'exécutif
français aurait pu anticiper certaines
choses incontestablement il suffit de
comparer avec nos voisins allemands deux
éléments sur le caine
les allemands on pu anticiper les tests
c'est à dire que la raison pour
lesquelles il ya beaucoup moins de morts
en allemagne au france aujourd'hui ou
ailleurs c'est parce qu'il ya eu tout de
suite une ultime but est massif et ça on
en était incapable appart on est capable
de faire des tests pour été incapables
et d'isoler les personnes malades
d'isoler les personnes qui avaient été
au tour des personnes malades et 2
éviter la propagation d'épidémies douce
au profil mans drastique la question
aussi d'élire respiratoires ça fait
maintenant deux ans que les soignants
sont mobilisent pour demander pour jouer
dans les hôpitaux pour les a pas écoutés
bilan est arrivé au début de la crise
avec même pas ça me lie aux capacités
les allemands et les 20000 vous voyez
bien que non c'est faux de dire que tous
les goûts les mêmes réactions
yaounde pays fois parce que vous avez
des capacités industrielles plus forte
vous avez pu conserver
tu vois pas ce qu'il y'a une meilleure
anticipation et s'en sont mieux sorties
gouvernement français alors très
rapidement on n'a plus beaucoup de temps
vous proposer à la france a soumis ce
propose de planifier la sortie de crise
on est enfin la sortie du du confinement
on est en plein dedans qu'est ce que
vous préconisez nous y compris que dont
la diminution était au gouvernement
aujourd'hui on proposerait une réunion à
tous nos partenaires sociaux les
syndicats les chefs d'entreprise le
gouvernement pour orienter l'économie
parce que la question n est pas
seulement de réussir les confinements
faut savoir comment on produit des bases
gratuit quant aux produits des tests
mais aussi par exemple comment on
s'assure effectivement qu'il y avait une
relocalisation sanitaires comme on
s'assure qu'une entreprise comme ça ne
le fit donc soit pas 100 millions de
l'état par an en crédit impôt recherche
en disant qu'elle va prioriser les états
unis pour le vaccin qu'elle pourrait
trouver donc ça ça veut dire qu'il faut
planifier c'est l'état qui doit indiquer
le cas et qui doit faire en sorte que on
le suit voilà ce que vous proposons
c'est pas depuis ce qui est fait et puis
dernier point c'est que cette crise est
d'autres malheureusement notamment des
crises environnementales et on ne peut
pas recommencer comme avant
voilà cette mise à jour au moins la
qualité de baisser le taux de co2 au
niveau mondial nous vous proposons de
réorienter l'économie vers une
transition énergétique et on sait qu'au
de planification c'est pas le marché de
cussol qui peut décider des choses
eric coquerel merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
député la france insoumise de seine
saint denis et merci d'avoir est en
direct avec nous